in full disclosure i was an angel
investor in robin hood before they
launched
and when i met the founder vlad and his
partner
you know they pitched me at a a bar not
too far from where we are right now in
palo alto called antonio's nuthouse
and my friend adeo it's a really good
story
my friend adeo had asked me to speak at
his founders institute which is kind of
like an
accelerator for people who are thinking
about starting a company yes
and so i gave a talk and then he said
hey let's go to antonio's nut house and
um
we'll meet elon for a drink uh and so
elon met us for a drink there
and it's it's the divest of dive bars
like you'll
take a beer love the image of all of
this you hang out with elon
dirt on the floor yeah i mean it is the
worst bar in the peninsula
like just garbage on the floor and like
cheap beer
and warm beer and like you pick up your
pine glass to be lipstick on it
it's just brutal classy not your
lipstick you understand somebody else's
lipstick yes
and so we're sitting there and
vlad walks up with um his partner and he
says here jason calacanis and i said
tell me about your startup he said how
do you know i have a startup i said you
recognize me
and i mean that's the only way and he
goes is that elon musk and i said yes
elon come
say hi and he came over and said i said
tell me what you do he said well i'm a
quant
i said what's that and he said
quantitative
analysis and i was like oh yeah i know
about that that's like you guys make
algorithms and then try to beat the
market right he's like yeah i was like
so you're gonna pitch me on a startup
and you're gonna sell your algorithm to
other people
and if it was so good why wouldn't you
just use it yourself and print money
he's like yeah no no that's not our
business our businesses
we're going to create an app to get
millennials to trade stocks
and i said you do realize there's no
retail investors anymore like the dot
com crash plus the 2008 financial crisis
eliminated any individual's belief in
participating in the stock market
and he said that's the opportunity i
said okay i like it tell me more
he said well we're going to get these
millennials to trade i said the same
ones
who live in their mom's basements and
take uber and lyft
and are on their parents have no money
got screwed and
you know went 250k into debt for school
and now can't get a job those people
and he's like yeah i'm like okay they
have no interest in their future but
they're going to trade stocks he said
yeah that's the opportunity i was like
how do you how are you going to make
money
and he said well that's the best part
it's going to be free
and i said so your idea is to get a
group of people who have no interest in
saving for their future
to trade and your business model is free
and he said yes i said i'm in
because in almost all cases the crazy
outlandish ideas
that nobody believes in are the ones
that have the greatest returns i mean
uber
i introduced to about 25 investors and
three of us said yes
so you know a full 12 percent of the
community
who saw that deal decided to do it so
the your sense about this idea being
good
had to do with the fact that this guy
was just uh crazy and ambitious and bold
thinking or was it that there's
something here
in allowing a much larger magnitude of
people to be able to be investors
yeah the way to do really well as an
angel investor or
just in technology or in life is to not
say what could go wrong but to say what
could go
right and then to just imagine for a
moment if
it does work what would the world look
like and so when elon was investing
in tesla and some other guys were
running it
and he was trying to save the company um
you know it wasn't is this going to work
it was
almost positively not going to work it
was and he knew that
but if it does work what does the world
look like and so that's really what
you're looking for
is not the chances of success
but if it does succeed does succeed what
would that look like and
you that's what the world needs more
people doing and so when you looked at
robin hood it was like well if he does
succeed what would the world look like
and now we've seen what it looks like
you have a generation who are so
financially sophisticated
that they know how to do puts and calls
and shorts
and research at a level
that dominated the hedge fund industry
so let's pause for a second
these traders sitting there on a
subreddit in a discord server
are able to do analysis and research and
then act in unison
to say we're going to beat in the robin
hood
sense uh you know this group of
sophisticated insiders who have
more access and more access to capital
but we will
figure out how to solve this problem and
you know things
most things don't work it's like the
wikipedia like
there's no way no way the wikipedia
would ever work right
except it did yeah right like you're
like how is this ever gonna work
you're not paying anybody but it's both
the largest corpus
of an encyclopedia ever so i think robin
hood actually succeeded and then what we
saw was
this system and a lot of the systems in
our society
whether it's the political system the
constitution of the united states
uh education higher education which
you're involved in uh
and then even the financial system we
have not stress tested
and stress tested it and we don't
actually know
all the edge cases and how it works so
trump was able to just
really put this crazy stress test like
it
is the democracy going to hold are we
going to break this
two or three you know 200 someone year
old experiment and then we looked at the
financial markets and it turns out
there were more people shorting the
stock than stocks where the shares were
available
i don't know how that's possible and
then i'm trying to uncover
where can i see a list of people who've
shorted the stock and it's like you
can't
but we can tell you sort of how many
every two weeks or maybe twice a week we
can create a report
maybe we know
you